foreign
by train is to travel with weapons false
other reasons include but are not
limited to meeting Donald Gleason and or
Mary Weaver for an affair playing
cribbage with a random stranger before
finding out what baby tastes like also I
know this particular train car is so
hard Edge that they drink alcohol from
Taps that look like snakes but why is
there a knock dispenser at every table
no one who enters this car would come
unprepared to the point that this bar
freely hands out brass knuckles at each
individual table would they and yes this
is the Rick and Morty where the creators
decided nothing matters so it's our job
to say that everything does take that
logic who are you
dirty sanchez Rick is clearly firing
toward the ceiling and some of these
shots yet everyone hits its Mark did he
purchase a zorg zf1 from Gary Oldman
even in a simulation or whatever you
want to call this why not drink this
potion sooner
two buttholes is a true waste of real
estate I don't accept your weird leap
and logic that has everyone on a train
going to kill one guy I'm wondering who
made the decision to animate Jeremy from
CinemaSins in this way why would we take
turns telling stories about it like
little girls had to sleep over they are
called slumber parties and you sir are a
meanie what is with the Rick Sanchez
Obsession I know right and which Rick
Sanchez are you even talking about
there's like a whole Citadel of them
this show plays so fast and loose with
its Ricks that I never know which one is
the real Rick and which ones aren't it
gets confusing you don't see us just
switching channel narrators in the
middle of a video without ever
explaining it I mean can you imagine I
know this story is BS but how the [ __ ]
did that Christmas tree jump from the
right side of the window to all the way
over to the left side of the window
Morty and summer were hanging ornaments
on it when Rick walked in now they're
nowhere near it also good to see that
they've managed to set up only one glass
of wine on this table before bringing
out the turkey none of my business but
he didn't even save Christmas in that
story this whole episode would be
excellent at TV sins oh you don't have
to pretend you didn't date him we all
did now a lot of you will be focused on
Yoda in this shot but I'm more focused
on the fact that Rick dated Quinn
morgendorfer Total Recall Sophia Vergara
and Conan O'Brien also if you're an
octopus how do you pick which lake the
Garter goes on is it like a wedding ring
situation it's not a real train it's a
story device okay guys if you're gonna
do all our work for us what are we
supposed to even do show random pictures
of adorable cat costumes if we wanted
one off you do interdimensional cable
this episode is interdimensional cable
only this time Rick and Morty is the
show that they keep flipping to it's
like Rick and Morty an Inception just
had a threesome baby with Debs it's Rick
and Morty entering their own portal like
Malkovich did in Being John Malkovich
that sounds like it should be a sin
removal so it won't be since nothing
makes sense in this episode I'm going to
remove a sin for the oversized tickets
Please arcade game with a huge monitor
that requires a seat a VR helmet and a
giant console to play ever give me
tickets
ruining your grandkids birthday this
could come in handy so in this literally
metaphorical literal metaphor Anthology
Story train air is continuity does that
even mean anything does anything mean
anything sorry didn't it picks her
sorry to nitpick doesn't that mean those
two could be any Rick and Morty has
blown up continuity as we know it but
what I really want to know is why are
there tally marks on the wall suggesting
that someone was trapped here for 10
days even in this Wacky World it's hard
to believe that Rick and Morty can punch
somebody just once and they die
instantly of course this thing is just a
circle the first image of this episode
is a regular ass looking train in Space
the track might be circular but the
train isn't there's probably a point to
this but I'm too lazy to look it up we
don't have to do anything Morty this is
just a structural guide we're obviously
going to impart our own style I don't
like how meta this is getting rich you
know I've watched this episode five
times and a lot of it feels like the
writers were going through a therapy
session like they're worried that their
original show might get stale it's like
a palette cleanser but after waiting for
this show to come back since 2017
waiting two years to get half of a
season and waiting another four months
for the next episode I'm not sure I
really needed an episode where the
writers obsessed over their own creation
what's funny is that a year from now
this episode will be just another
episode in the pressure to be great will
be completely gone this sounds like it
should be a sin so I'm removing one shut
up Morty you're 14 you watch videos of
people on YouTube reacting to [ __ ]
YouTube bet you really felt that one
Dave huh I'll be the judge of when we
get too meta look I don't have a problem
with the meta I have a problem with when
the meta becomes a lazy excuse just to
do whatever you want and pretend it's
clever like when YouTube channels get an
easy laugh by accusing the show they're
dissecting of doing the very thing that
people accuse them of doing oh wink a
wink what's happening going into an act
break you know it's kind of like they're
trying to steal our job and break our
will so hard that it never returns like
when parents find their kids with
cigarettes and force them to smoke the
whole pack bad news dad our lungs were
made for this I'm a bird and a person
and more sure that was a great moment
why is it that in this train car that
people get a stage to tell their Rick
and Morty stories also taping photos on
curtains we've been here a really long
time and nobody's taking our tickets how
does a guy suspended in disbelief in
space gather up enough momentum to
suddenly appear for a joke I just
answered my own question didn't I Rick
and Morty just made the most TV since
proof episode ever with this thing
didn't they or should I say the most TV
since debunked episode ever
cutesy name news meet insert joke here
sin stop thinking and do it uh okay uh
there was this my name is Mike Johnson
that's good coffee wait is this how
Morty is telling the story or is this
the representation of the story Morty is
telling I mean is Morty Standing On Top
of the train saying my name is Mike
Johnson that's good coffee or is he
talking about a guy named Mike Johnson
who likes coffee why is lesbian part of
her job title now you're Progressive
foreign
I love you ever since you were mailed to
me by a doctor woman this is a brilliant
deconstruction of the bechdel test
mainly the idea that some people have
that following it inherently creates a
great narrative Jurassic world passed
the big deal test fight them with your
heavy special time you do it too
wow you know what's really special about
summer and Beth's heavy special time
their pants stay completely intact that
new brand of Kotex is phenomenal I'm
that Supreme Court lady and you [ __ ]
did it I don't know if this actually
passes the bechdel test Beth was called
Mom and Morty couldn't even remember
Ruth Bader ginsburg's name so I'm not
sure there are two or more named females
in this story
Rick save Morty by plugging his oxygen
into Morty's helmet but when Rick Falls
they are no longer connected and sure
Morty could hold his breath for a few
seconds but why do both of their helmets
now have hoses plugged into them don't
worry Morty nothing out there is Canon
as if it matters the show is to Canon
like the dursleys are to Harry Potter it
throws it under the stairs and only lets
it see the light of day when it
absolutely has to
if continuity doesn't matter then this
one ball that was definitely coming
towards Rick shouldn't be coming towards
Rick in the next shot it should be a
lizard at this point am I giving this
show a sin for not breaking continuity
yes I am who the [ __ ] am I not real
nothing's real you can tell because not
only do these officers arrive five
seconds after Rick is stabbed they come
from two different directions did the
third one run in and then around the
camera and then in from the other side
well it's nice to see their cuts and
bruises from the rest of this fight have
healed up so nicely is this intentional
maybe does it matter lasagna I take all
the sins back if this ends with one of
these two bringing the other one back to
life and then exchanging a kiss that is
somehow both platonic and romantic Even
Rick and Morty can't help but play the
hits for a cheap thrill and if you don't
think it's a cheap thrill explain to me
again how the me seeks play into this
scene in any way whatsoever I'll wait
time's up they don't thank you for
sending your only begotten
what are you doing you guys would never
do this okay I understand that this guy
represents the fans and or the network
but if Rick and Morty started praying
like this everybody would know it's
building to a joke which is exactly what
this does complete with a VeggieTales
reference I mean even if this happened
for real we laugh because it's so
anti-vim listening to Rick's voice is
funny enough that they could do a whole
episode in church with him playing a
pastor and it would be funny somehow I'm
thinking it would be funny somehow I beg
your pardon well it is Jesus and they're
in a machine so this is his deus ex
machina as it gets and I think that
deserves a sent off
so what do you think haha you thought
this was a big play on the setting of
snow piercer but it turns out it was a
big play on a scene from the 1991 Adams
Family
haha you thought this was a big play on
the setting of snow piercer which turned
out to be a big play on a scene from the
1991 Adams Family but it was actually a
big play on a scene from Ant-Man
nobody's out there shopping with this
holy way to get that in there at the
last minute we know how long it takes to
get one of these episodes done and to do
some timely last second thing like this
that's awesome but now that I think of
it why is this episode titled never
ricking Morty is that a play on the
never-ending story does that work on any
level is it a joke a play on words does
this episode have anything to do with
that movie does a horse get real sad and
die they should have just called it
throw logic from the train and been done
with it right now look it up it's real
it's not
foreign
make sure you click that Bell Icon by
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click it sell out
[Music]
oh that's funny you're gonna look
funnier sucking my with no teeth so why
did you date Rick Sanchez anything you'd
like to eat
Turkish delight why is there a dead man
in the sky if it's any consolation he
had very few loved ones maybe what
matters is to love yourself first and
soar child of air and land with wings
and hands yes you're a bird and a person
guess who's got two penises and all the
agency did you make a penis dude